Watching officials from international soccer this week on the news, it was hard not to think, wow, you guys have really learned how to have a game face. You know what I'm talking about? 14 people indicted, many arrested, allegations of bribery and corruption going back years-- the head of FIFA, Sepp Blatter, was not indicted, but people were wondering about his involvement. And law enforcement officials have made clear their investigation is not finished. But Blatter was cool. He was composed at the opening ceremony at the FIFA Congress on Thursday.
这周在新闻里看到国际足联的官员们，很难不让人感叹，哇，你们这副“扑克脸”练得可真是炉火纯青。你们知道我在说什么吧？14人被起诉，多人被捕，涉及多年来的贿赂和腐败指控——国际足联主席塞普·布拉特虽然没有被起诉，但人们都在怀疑他是否牵涉其中。执法官员已明确表示调查尚未结束。但布拉特表现得很淡定。周四在国际足联大会的开幕式上，他显得沉着冷静。
Many people hold me ultimately responsible for the actions and the reputation of the global football community. We, or I, cannot monitor everyone all of the time. If people want to do wrong, they will also tried to hide it.
许多人认为我对全球足球界的行为和声誉负有最终责任。我们，或者说我，不可能时刻监控所有人。如果人们想做坏事，他们也会试图掩盖。
By the next day, though, cracks started to appear if you were watching closely, which I was. It was little things. Like, for example, on Thursday Blatter had said--
不过到了第二天，如果你仔细观察——我确实一直在观察——就会发现裂痕开始显现。都是些小事。例如，周四布拉特曾说——
These are unprecedented and difficult times for FIFA.
对于国际足联而言，这是史无前例且艰难的时刻。
One day later, though, he told the Congress, quote, "I will not call this unprecedented." Apparently somebody reminded him of accusations of bribery and financial mismanagement under his leadership in 2002, 2006, 2010, and 2011. That day, Friday, Blatter addressed the FIFA Congress in French. And even the question of his responsibility as FIFA's president seemed to shift like soft ground yielding under a heavyweight.
然而一天后，他对大会说，引用他的原话：“我不会称之为史无前例。”显然有人提醒了他，在他领导下，2002年、2006年、2010年和2011年都曾出现过贿赂和财务管理不善的指控。那天是周五，布拉特用法语向国际足联大会发表了讲话。甚至连他作为国际足联主席的责任问题，似乎也像承重物下的松软地面一样开始动摇。
I'm willing to accept that the president of FIFA is responsible for everything, but I would like to share that responsibility with you, or at the very least with the executive committee here to my left.
我愿意接受国际足联主席对一切负责，但我希望与你们，或者至少与我左手边的执行委员会分享这份责任。
Sometimes, during this address, Blatter's words seemed totally disconnected from his tone. He issued a rallying cry at one point, "let's try to lift our spirits," with the grimness of a doctor delivering awful medical news and an actual grimace at the end, which is to say, even somebody with as much game face as a veteran political operator like Blatter-- he's been part of FIFA's leadership for decades. Even he has his limits.
有时候，在这番讲话中，布拉特的话语与他的语调完全脱节。他在某一刻发出了战斗号角：“让我们试着振奋精神，”但这听起来却像是一位医生在传达糟糕的医疗诊断，最后甚至还带有一个真正的苦笑，也就是说，即使是像布拉特这样经验丰富的政治操盘手——他在国际足联高层已经待了几十年——即便拥有如此强悍的“扑克脸”，他也是有极限的。
One of our producers, Jonathan, has this picture in his middle school yearbook, his team picture for sixth grade basketball at Hillview Middle School in Whittier, California. Out of 20 kids, most of them are stony-faced. A few smile or smirk a little bit. He is the only one beaming. He says he didn't get the memo to look tough. It reminded me we have to be taught to have a game face. We have to be taught. It doesn't just happen. Somebody was telling me last week about his daughter's softball league, that they actively coach them on this, on not to cry, not to get upset when there's a bad call or the game doesn't go their way. Don't look like you're losing it, the coach tells the kids. Keep your face neutral. Look like you're in control. That's the key. Look like you're in control.
我们的制片人之一乔纳森，在他初中毕业纪念册里有张照片，是他六年级在加州惠蒂尔希尔维尤中学参加篮球队的照片。20个孩子里，大多数人都表情僵硬。少数几个露出一丝微笑或傻笑。只有他笑得灿烂无比。他说他没收到“要装得强硬点”的通知。这提醒了我，我们必须被教导如何保持“扑克脸”。我们必须受过训练。它不会凭空出现。上周有人跟我提起他女儿的垒球队，说教练会积极教她们这一点，教她们不要哭，不要在裁判判罚不公或比赛不顺时情绪失控。别表现出你快崩溃的样子，教练告诉孩子们。保持面部表情中立。表现得尽在掌控。这是关键。表现得尽在掌控。
Well , today our program, we have stories of people in situations that are fraught and difficult, where anybody would have trouble staying composed. But above all, for various reasons in each story, these people have to stay composed. They have to maintain gain phase, which is when you are truly being tested. From WBEZ Chicago, it's "This American Life". I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
好吧，今天我们的节目，我们将讲述人们在充满压力和困境的处境中，任何人在那种情况下都难以保持冷静的故事。但最重要的是，出于每个故事中的不同原因，这些人必须保持冷静。他们必须维持“扑克脸”，这正是对他们真正的考验。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1, "200 Dog Night."
第一幕，“200条狗之夜”。
For a couple summers when she was 19 and 20, Blair Braverman worked as a dog sled guide on an Alaskan glacier. The glacier was part of an ice field the size of Rhode Island made of many glaciers. Blair and 12 other staff members lived with 200 huskies on the ice for a week at a time. Sometimes, actually, it was a lot more than a week. They'd be there for three or four weeks. The guides slept in tents. The dogs slept in little plastic igloos.
布莱尔·布拉弗曼19和20岁时的几个夏天，曾在阿拉斯加的一座冰川上担任狗拉雪橇向导。那座冰川是一个像罗德岛州那么大的冰原的一部分，由许多冰川组成。布莱尔和其他12名工作人员一次要在冰上和200只哈士奇一起生活一周。有时，实际上远不止一周。他们会在那里待上三到四周。向导们睡在帐篷里，狗狗们睡在塑料小冰屋里。
And, eight times a day, helicopters would drop off groups of 20 to 30 cruise ship tourists. Of course, like any job dealing with the public, especially a job dealing with tourists, this all required a pretty committed game face, not just stoic, but actively cheerful, and enthusiastic, and-- F-U-N-- fun-- you know, on a glacier-- 'til one day that game face became very, very hard to pull off. Quick note-- we've changed some of the names in this story. Here's Blair.
而且，直升机会每天八次运送20到30名邮轮游客前来。当然，像所有与公众打交道的工作一样，尤其是处理游客的工作，这一切都需要非常敬业的“扑克脸”，不仅要冷峻，还要积极欢快、热情，还要——有意思——你知道的——在冰川上——直到有一天，那种“扑克脸”变得非常、非常难以维持。简短提醒一下——我们更改了这个故事中的一些人名。这是布莱尔。
The tour was expensive. Tourists paid $500 each for a half hour helicopter flight and a dog sled ride on the glacier-- total time on the ice, one hour. A lot of my earnings came from tips-- 20s, 50s, or the occasional hundred folded tight and slipped into my jacket cuff as I shook hands at the end of the tour. My job was to provide a luxury experience, a taste of real Alaska. This is from a promo video for the tour.
旅行很贵。每位游客支付500美元，享受半小时的直升机飞行和冰川上的狗拉雪橇之旅——在冰上的总时间为一小时。我的很多收入来自小费——20美元、50美元，偶尔是一张折得紧紧的百元大钞，在旅程结束握手时滑进我的袖口。我的工作是提供一种奢华的体验，一种真正的阿拉斯加风情。这来自该旅游项目的宣传视频。
The sled dogs we have at camp are the real McCoy. These are the dogs that we travel with in the winter and race with. Most of these dogs that will be pulling you today have actually done the Iditarod, many of them several times.
我们营地的雪橇犬都是正宗的。这些就是我们在冬天旅行和比赛时用的狗。今天带你们拉车的这些狗，大多都参加过艾迪塔罗德狗拉雪橇比赛，很多甚至参加过多次。
We were supposed to provide this taste of Alaska with absolutely no discomfort, either physical or mental, even though physical and mental discomfort is kind of the premise of living on a glacier. It could be brutal. UV rays reflected off the ice and blistered the insides of our nostrils so that it hurt to breathe. It rained a lot, and my skin got so waterlogged that it fell off in white strips. I wrapped my fingers in duct tape to keep the skin in one piece when I shook hands with tourists.
我们本应在完全没有生理或心理不适的情况下提供这种阿拉斯加体验，尽管生理和心理上的不适正是生活在冰川上的前提。环境可能很残酷。紫外线从冰面上反射出来，灼伤了我们鼻腔内部，以至于呼吸都疼。雨下得很多，我的皮肤变得水肿，成块地脱落。我用胶带裹住手指，这样在和游客握手时皮肤还能保持完整。
The snow we stood on was just a few feet deep, covering solid ice. But the ice would shift and crack. And so, under any given patch of snow, there might be ice, or there might be nothing, a gaping hole hundreds of feet deep. During my job interview, I'd been told that no staff members had died yet. But they couldn't make any promises.
我们脚下的雪只有几英尺深，覆盖着坚硬的冰层。但冰层会移动和开裂。所以，在任何一块雪地下面，可能是冰，也可能什么都没有，是一个几百英尺深的裂口。面试时，我被告知目前还没有员工死亡。但他们不能做出任何保证。
Once in a while, we'd spend a day probing for cracks in the ice, crevasses. We pushed long, thin aluminum poles into the snow every 12 inches or so through the whole camp, praying that the metal would meet resistance. One morning, I climbed from my tent to find that a turquoise lake a half mile wide had appeared overnight right next to camp. It was gone by the next day.
偶尔，我们会花一天时间探测冰层上的裂缝——冰隙。我们把长而细的铝杆每隔12英寸左右扎进整个营地的雪里，祈祷金属能碰到阻力。一天早上，我从帐篷里爬出来，发现营地旁边竟然一夜之间出现了一个半英里宽的绿松石色湖泊。到了第二天它就不见了。
On a bad day, we called the glacier the goddamn ice cube-- on a good day, summer camp on the moon. To the tourists, we called it dog world, as in, welcome to dog world. I'm Blair, and I'll be your dog sled guide. I can't believe how lucky we got with this weather. Eight times a day, I told the tourists that they had lucked into the best weather in weeks. Even when it was pouring rain, I explained that, until they arrived, it had been raining harder.
糟糕的日子里，我们管冰川叫“该死的冰块”——心情好的时候，叫它“月球上的夏令营”。对游客，我们称之为“狗狗世界”，比如，欢迎来到狗狗世界。我是布莱尔，我将是你们的狗拉雪橇向导。真不敢相信我们碰上这么好的天气。每天八次，我告诉游客他们碰上了几周来最好的天气。即使下着倾盆大雨，我也解释说，在他们到达之前，雨下得更大。
We tried to spare them the sight of a single piece of dog poop. We cleaned the kennel constantly, scraping up dog hair that collected on the snow and piling it in an enormous mound hidden behind the tents, which we called the woolly mammoth. The tourists didn't mention crevasses, so I didn't either. It wasn't that the reality of glacier life was a secret. We just didn't want to distract from the tourist fantasy that they had been dropped into a pristine wonderland.
我们尽量避免让他们看到哪怕一点狗屎。我们不停地清理犬舍，刮掉积在雪地上的狗毛，堆在帐篷后面一个巨大的土堆里，我们管它叫“长毛象”。游客们没提冰隙，所以我也不提。并不是冰川生活的现实是个秘密。我们只是不想破坏游客幻想，不想让他们觉得这并不是一片纯净的仙境。
By my second summer on the ice, I was having a hard time. Most of the other guides were men and older than me, so I was pretty lonely. To make it worse, I'd made the mistake of dating one of the men the summer before and then breaking up, which didn't exactly make it easy to live together at glacier camp. My ex had taken to badmouthing me to the other staff and even to the tourists. It's too bad you didn't get an experienced guide, I once overheard him tell a couple as he led them to my sled.
在冰上生活的第二个夏天，我过得很艰难。大多数其他向导都是男性，年纪也比我大，所以我感到很孤独。更糟糕的是，我前一年夏天犯了个错误，和一个男人约会，然后分手了，这使得在冰川营地共同生活变得并不容易。我的前任开始向其他员工甚至游客说我的坏话。我曾无意中听到他带着一对游客走向我的雪橇时说：“真遗憾你没分到一个有经验的向导。”
My tentmate, Rebecca, was my closest friend on the ice, although I thought of her more like a kid sister. She was a homeschooled 18-year-old from Indiana who had never before been away from her family for more than a week. She'd fallen in love with the idea of dogsledding, the idea of Alaska. And, back home, she saved up money working at McDonald's to buy a malamute and a husky, which she trained to pull her on roller blades. Rebecca lived her life, in her words, guided by Jesus Christ and his teachings.
我的帐篷室友丽贝卡是我在冰上最亲密的朋友，尽管我更把她当成小妹妹。她是个来自印第安纳州的18岁女孩，一直在家受教育，从未离开过家人超过一周。她迷上了狗拉雪橇的概念，迷上了阿拉斯加。在家时，她靠在麦当劳打工存钱买了一只阿拉斯加雪橇犬和一只哈士奇，并训练它们拉着她滑旱冰。用她的话说，丽贝卡的余生是由耶稣基督及其教诲指引的。
Together, she and I made easy targets. Other guides blamed us for problems around camp. And we were always the butt of their jokes. I was pretty resigned to it all, but sweet Rebecca was determined to make friends, going out of her way to be helpful, working twice as hard as any of the rest of us. And she dreamed of getting a chance to drive a dogsled. She'd set aside time for it. And somehow, just when she was getting hopeful, someone would yell that they needed her to scoop poop or fetch some booties. And the trip would be delayed again.
我和她在一起，成了现成的靶子。其他向导把营地周围的问题都怪罪到我们头上。我们总是他们笑话的对象。我对这一切感到相当无奈，但可爱的丽贝卡决心要交朋友，总是竭尽全力提供帮助，干的活比我们任何人都多。她梦想着有机会驾驶雪橇。她腾出了时间。但不知为何，每当她充满希望时，总有人大喊需要她去铲屎或拿靴子。于是行程又会被耽搁。
At night, Rebecca and I would sit up in our sleeping bags eating trail mix and trading young adult novels about the end of the world. We'd been on the glacier for two months, more than half the summer, and Rebecca still hadn't driven a dogsled. And she was really, really homesick.
晚上，我和丽贝卡会坐在睡袋里吃着干果，交换阅读关于世界末日的青少年小说。我们在冰川上待了两个月，超过了夏天的一半，丽贝卡还没开过狗拉雪橇。她真的、真的很想家。
Finally, she gave in and bought a plane ticket to see her family. When the morning came for her to leave, I begged for an hour off so I could take her sledding before she left. It was the best ride I'd had all summer. The dogs were happy. It wasn't raining, and Rebecca laughed out loud as she drove the sled. Tourist voices drifted from the neighboring trails, where other people were responsible for them.
最后，她屈服了，买了张机票去看家人。离别的那天早上，我恳求了十分钟假期，好在出发前带她去滑雪橇。那是我整个夏天滑得最好的一次。狗儿们很高兴。没下雨，丽贝卡在驾驶雪橇时放声大笑。邻近雪道上传来游客的声音，那是其他人负责照顾的游客。
Then we heard the high whine of a snowmobile and saw a tiny figure in the distance, our manager, Malcolm, zooming toward us in an orange vest. We had been warned about orange vests. They were worn only to signal an emergency, to communicate urgency to the staff without scaring the tourists. Now, as he barreled up the trail, Malcolm waved to the tourists. Gorgeous day, isn't it? He slowed next to me and Rebecca. We're in trouble, he said. The pilots can't get back.
然后我们听到了雪地摩托的高频轰鸣声，看到远处有一个小小的身影，我们的经理马尔科姆穿着橙色背心朝我们疾驰而来。我们被警告过橙色背心。它们只在紧急情况时穿，为了在不吓到游客的情况下传达紧迫感。现在，当他沿着雪道疾驰而来时，马尔科姆向游客挥了挥手。“天气真好，不是吗？”他在我和丽贝卡身边减速。“我们遇到麻烦了，”他说，“飞行员回不来了。”
A sudden storm had descended between the heliport and the glacier. Nobody's hurt, but the tourists are trapped here now, Malcolm said. His voice was higher than I've ever heard it. They're trapped here. I need you to let the staff know what happened without alarming any of the tourists. Just tell them-- I don't know-- that they'll be here longer than they expected, maybe an extra hour or two. More for their money, right? He paused. And girls, try to make it sound like a good thing.
一场突如其来的暴风雪阻隔了直升机机场和冰川。“没人受伤，但游客现在被困在这里了，”马尔科姆说。他的声音比我听过的任何时候都要尖。“他们被困在这里了。我需要你们在不惊动任何游客的情况下通知员工。就告诉他们——我不知道——告诉他们行程会比预期的长，可能多待一两个小时。钱花得更值，对吧？”他停顿了一下。“姑娘们，尽量让这听起来像件好事。”
Rebecca and I split up to spread the word. Great news, I announced to each group. You get a longer tour than usual. Then, while the tourists pet the dogs, I sidled up to each musher and quietly told him what was actually going on. Back at camp, Malcolm was standing by the satellite phone thinking. He had called the cruise ship to say that the passengers would be late. The captain agreed to wait three hours, but no longer. So our cook heated a massive pot on the propane stove, preparing cocoa.
丽贝卡和我分头去散布消息。“天大的好消息，”我向每一组宣布。“你们可以享受比平时更长的游览时间。”然后，当游客们抚摸狗狗时，我溜到每个赶车人身边，悄悄告诉他们到底发生了什么。在营地，马尔科姆站在卫星电话旁思考。他打给邮轮公司说乘客会晚点。船长同意等待三小时，但不能再长了。于是我们的厨师在丙烷炉上加热了一个大锅，准备做热可可。
Our goal now was to keep things fun for as long as possible, let the tourists hang out in the kennel, then bring them in for hot drinks. Malcolm had plans for snowmobile rides and a snowman building contest. As long as the backup helicopters arrived within an hour or so, which they would, there was no reason for the tourists to know that things weren't going just as intended. But the weather only got worse.
我们现在的目标是尽可能让游客玩得开心，让他们在犬舍闲逛，然后带他们去喝热饮。马尔科姆计划了雪地摩托兜风和堆雪人比赛。只要救援直升机在一小时左右内到达——他们本该如此——游客就没有理由知道事情并没有按计划进行。但天气却变得更糟。
We brought the tourists to the community tent and fed them cookies. Malcolm delivered the solemn news. The helicopters were grounded. The storm had blocked their flight path, and immediate rescue was doubtful. No, a man said. That can't be. My ship leaves at 8:00. Others nodded in agreement. The snow, the ice, being trapped-- it wasn't a possibility.
我们把游客带到公共帐篷里喂他们吃饼干。马尔科姆宣布了严峻的消息。直升机停飞了。暴风雪阻挡了航线，短期内获救的可能性很小。“不，”一个男人说，“这不可能。我的船8点开。”其他人点头表示同意。大雪、冰层、被困——这不在考虑范围内。
Then the tourists got angry at the guides for bringing them there, at the pilots for misjudging the weather, at the cruise ships for not waiting. Didn't we understand that this was a serious inconvenience? One woman had left her infant with a baby sitter. A couple was worried about standing up a dinner date. A few people raised concerns about medication they had left back on the ship.
然后游客们开始对导游把他们带到这里感到愤怒，对飞行员误判天气感到愤怒，对邮轮公司不愿多等感到愤怒。他们难道不明白这是严重的不便吗？一位女士把婴儿留给了保姆。一对夫妇担心耽误了晚餐约会。几个人担心他们留在船上的药物。
We have a cook, Malcolm said to the tourists. We have plenty of food and water, and we're going to make this as fun for you as we can. Right now, the mushers will go back out to their dogs. And anyone who wants can go on as many dog sled rides as they'd like. The tourists looked dismayed. Malcolm gave them a pleasant nod and stepped outside, gesturing for the staff to follow. I don't care what you need to do, he whispered once we had gathered around him. Just keep them happy. Do whatever it takes. Act like this is the best thing that's ever happened to you. And for heaven's sake, don't do anything that could get us sued.
“我们有厨师，”马尔科姆对游客说，“我们有充足的食物和水，我们会尽量让这段时间过得愉快。现在，赶车人将回到他们的狗身边。任何想玩的人都可以尽可能多地去坐狗拉雪橇。”游客们看起来很沮丧。马尔科姆对他们点头致意，走到外面，示意员工跟上。“我不管你们要做什么，”我们在他身边围拢后，他低声说，“只要让他们高兴。不惜一切代价。表现得这就像你们经历过的最好的事一样。看在上帝的份上，别做任何可能让我们被告上法庭的事。”
That afternoon passed in a haze of card games, the tourists constantly checking their watches and their useless cell phones. Someone set up a badminton net in the snow, and a few of the younger tourists played a tournament. Then dusk fell, and it became clear that the tourists would be staying the night. Malcolm and the cook delivered the news alongside platters of meatloaf, mashed potatoes, and chocolate cake. Meanwhile, we guides squatted on our heels behind the storage tent and ate sandwiches, too grim to talk.
那个下午在扑克牌游戏中度过，游客们不停地看着手表和毫无用处的手机。有人在雪地里架起羽毛球网，几个年轻游客打了一场比赛。黄昏降临，很明显游客们要过夜了。马尔科姆和厨师在供应肉饼、土豆泥和巧克力蛋糕的同时宣布了消息。与此同时，我们向导蹲在储物帐篷后面吃三明治，心情沉重得说不出话。
The tourists were not happy. Here they were dressed in their cruise ship clothes, wearing these weird black overshoes they'd been given to wear on the ice, far away from their toothbrushes, and their pajamas, and their beds, and the breakfast buffets they had already paid for. They didn't understand why they hadn't been rescued. They didn't understand why the helicopters couldn't fly at night.
游客们很不高兴。他们穿着邮轮上的衣服，脚上穿着那种他们在冰上不得不穿的怪异黑色套鞋，远离他们的牙刷、睡衣、床，以及他们已经付过钱的早餐自助餐。他们不明白为什么没有获救。他们不明白为什么直升机不能在夜间飞行。
The storage tent held 30 emergency sleeping bags for just such a situation, although, in 10 years of tours, they'd never been opened. Malcolm told the staff that we would be ceding our tents and cots to the guests, as he insisted we call them. He went tent by tent to make sure the quarters were ready. Put all your stuff in trash bags, he told us. And we'll pile it outside. We want to make sure the guests are comfortable. Where are we going to sleep, Rebecca asked. Malcolm stepped out into the snow. I really don't care, he said.
储物帐篷里存放着30个应急睡袋，以备不时之需，尽管在10年的旅游中，它们从未打开过。马尔科姆告诉员工，我们将把帐篷和行军床让给客人——他坚持这么称呼。他一个帐篷一个帐篷地检查，确保住处准备好。“把你们的东西都装进垃圾袋，”他告诉我们，“我们会把它堆在外面。我们要确保客人住得舒服。”“我们要睡哪儿？”丽贝卡问。马尔科姆走到雪地里。“我根本不在乎，”他说。
Rebecca and I ended up sleeping on the floor of the veterinary tent. It reeked of piss and menthol. Neither of us could sleep. I whispered, how are you doing? My flight, she said, voice muffled by her pillow. And it took me a moment to follow. I had forgotten. It leaves the day after tomorrow, she said. I can't get a refund. I tried to think of something to say, some comfort that would make her feel better, but I was just so tired.
丽贝卡和我最后睡在兽医帐篷的地板上。那里弥漫着尿骚味和薄荷味。我们俩都睡不着。我低声问：“你怎么样？”“我的航班，”她说，声音被枕头闷住了。我过了一会儿才反应过来。我忘了。她说：“后天出发。我拿不到退款。”我试图想点什么说，一些能让她感觉好点的话，但我实在太累了。
The second day passed like the first, although the Parcheesi players had graduated to poker. Every so often, I'd peek into the storage tent to get medical updates. One of the other tourists was an insulin-dependent diabetic. If he were stuck on the ice for just one more day, there was a chance he could slip into a coma.
第二天像第一天一样过去，尽管玩“游戏棋”的人已经升级到玩扑克。我不时溜进储物帐篷获取医疗进展。其中一名游客患有胰岛素依赖型糖尿病。如果他再在冰上被困一天，他很有可能会陷入昏迷。
The word was that, back in civilization, a mountain rescue team was mobilizing, ready to cross the frozen wilderness with ropes and ice picks, carrying insulin and other medications in their packs. But nobody should know any of that, I was reminded. We had to give the impression that, even though we were trapped, everything was going to be just fine. The tourists were busy pining for their ships, for the vacations that had been only temporarily interrupted. And I was to keep it that way. So I returned to the tourists beaming.
消息传来说，在文明世界，救援队正在动员，准备带着绳索和冰镐穿过冰封的荒野，背包里装着胰岛素和其他药物。但没有人应该知道这些，有人提醒我。我们必须给人一种印象，尽管我们被困住了，但一切都会好起来的。游客们忙着想念他们的邮轮，想念那些只是暂时中断的假期。而我要保持那种状态。所以我带着灿烂的笑容回到游客身边。
When my face got sore from all the smiling, I retreated from the crowd, back to the diabetic man in one of the sleeping tents. He was middle aged. I think he was a banker. He sat on a cot breathing slowly. At one point, I drew a picture of him, a little sketch that he folded and tucked into his breast pocket. Then he took my hand. I'm honored to be spending this time with such a lovely young woman, he said. I squeezed his hand and felt like a liar.
当我的脸因为长时间微笑而发酸时，我从人群中撤出，回到睡眠帐篷里那个糖尿病患者身边。他是个中年人。我想他是个银行家。他坐在行军床上缓慢地呼吸。有一次，我给他画了一幅画，他把它折好，塞进衬衫口袋里。然后他握住我的手。“我很荣幸能和这么可爱的年轻女士共度这段时间，”他说。我握了握他的手，觉得自己像个骗子。
Late in the afternoon, we gathered the tourists in the community tent, planning to break the news about a possible second night. The tourists had been remarkably positive all day. They were troopers. Some of the younger tourists even helped feed the dogs, hauling buckets of soupy kibble from plastic igloo to plastic igloo. A few even sounded like they wanted to stay. I can't believe you get paid for this, they said, sipping their cocoa. If they could take three months off, they said, they'd love to come work here. This, Malcolm noted, was a resounding success. Still, I dreaded the possibility that they would stay for a second night. I thought that would be the breaking point, not just for the diabetic man, but for us, too. How long could we keep this up?
傍晚时分，我们把游客召集在公共帐篷里，准备宣布可能要待第二个晚上的消息。游客们一整天都表现得非常积极。他们表现得很坚强。一些年轻的游客甚至帮忙喂狗，拎着桶在塑料小冰屋之间来回奔波，分发粘稠的狗粮。有些人甚至听起来想留下来。他们喝着可可说，不敢相信你们的工作竟然报酬丰厚。他们说，如果能休三个月假，他们很乐意留下来工作。马尔科姆指出，这是一个巨大的成功。不过，我依然担心他们会待第二个晚上的可能。我想那将是临界点，不仅对那个糖尿病患者，对我们也是。我们还能坚持多久？
Not long after, we heard a thin rumble in the distance. Everyone froze. At first, I thought it was in my own head. No one had told us the helicopters were coming. But, as they rounded a mountain on the other side of the ice field, the tourists began to cheer. They rushed towards them, stumbling in the snow as the birds landed. In the sudden excitement, I stepped back and watched from the kennel, sitting on a plastic igloo as the guides helped the diabetic man into the first helicopter and the rest of the tourists into the others. Rebecca was able to slip onto the last helicopter, waving at me as she climbed aboard. We watched the helicopters disappear behind the mountains. In the silence that followed, even the dogs were quiet. We'd learn later that the hole in the storm that the helicopters flew through closed up just as fast as it opened, and the last helicopter, the one Rebecca was on, had to make an emergency landing at a lodge near the base of the glacier.
没过多久，我们听到远处传来隐约的隆隆声。每个人都僵住了。起初，我以为是我的错觉。没人告诉我们直升机要来。但当它们绕过冰原另一侧的山峰时，游客们开始欢呼。他们冲向那边，在雪地里跌跌撞撞，直升机降落了。在突如其来的兴奋中，我退后一步，坐在塑料冰屋上，看着向导们扶着糖尿病患者上第一架直升机，其他人上另外几架。丽贝卡溜上了最后一架直升机，爬上去时向我挥手。我们看着直升机消失在山后。随后的寂静中，连狗都安静了。后来我们才知道，直升机穿过的那个暴风雨缺口闭合得和打开时一样快，丽贝卡乘坐的那架直升机不得不在冰川脚下的一家旅馆紧急着陆。
The rest of us trudged back to the tents without speaking to each other. There were sleeping bags to pack up, dogs to feed, and trails to groom, and poop to shovel. In the morning, the helicopters would return, carrying a new group of tourists to experience real Alaska. Though we'd never match the tour we had just given, the tourists who got stuck, they'd paid $500, like all the rest, to experience real Alaska. And they were the only ones who really got what they came for.
我们其余的人默默地拖着步子回到帐篷。还有睡袋要收，狗要喂，雪道要修，粪便要铲。早上，直升机将返回，载着新一批游客来体验“真正的阿拉斯加”。虽然我们永远无法复刻我们刚刚提供的这次旅行，但那些被困住的游客，和其他人一样付了500美元来体验真正的阿拉斯加。而他们是唯一真正得到了所求之物的人。
Blair Braverman-- a version of this story is in a book that she's writing that's called, tentatively, "Welcome to the Goddamn Ice Cube". Next week, The  Atavist will publish a longer version of the story. That's at TheAtavist.com. By the way, we spoke to the dog sled company in this story. They said that they would never do anything to hide information from the tourists, though a former employee of the company did confirm Blair's account.
布莱尔·布拉弗曼——这个故事的一个版本出现在她正在撰写的书中，暂定名为《欢迎来到该死的冰块》。下周，《Atavist》杂志将发表这个故事的加长版。网址是 TheAtavist.com。顺便说一句，我们采访了故事里的那家狗拉雪橇公司。他们说绝不会向游客隐瞒信息，尽管该公司的一名前员工证实了布莱尔的描述。
[MUSIC  - "THE MAN" BY ALOE BLACC]
[音乐 - 阿洛·布莱克演唱的《The Man》]
Act 2, "Funny Face."
第二幕，“滑稽的脸。”
OK, most jobs require you to suck it up and keep a game face on, right? Keep game face on, even while things are going horribly-- that's true for anybody in sales. It's true for waiters and waitresses. It's true for every kind of performer. And, among performers, I think it might be most intense for stand-up comedians, because they're on stage alone. And, when comedy goes badly, you know, it gets very, very bleak. It gets very lonely. And they have to stay up there, doing their job for a group of people that is not into them at all. And they have to just keep going. They have to keep telling punchlines that just are getting nothing back, just crickets one after another after another. Not long ago, Tig Notaro had some shows like that.
好吧，大多数工作都需要你忍气吞声，保持“扑克脸”，对吧？即便事情进展得极其糟糕，也要保持“扑克脸”——这对销售人员来说是真的。对服务员来说是真的。对所有类型的表演者来说也是真的。而在表演者中，我认为这对脱口秀演员来说可能最强烈，因为他们是独自站在台上的。当喜剧表演砸了时，那种感觉非常非常凄凉。非常孤独。他们必须留在台上，为一群完全不买账的人表演。他们必须继续下去。他们必须不停地讲出毫无回应的笑话，冷场一个接一个。不久前，蒂格·诺塔罗就经历过几场那样的演出。
I performed in Vegas. When you perform in Vegas, you do a week of shows. There's two shows a night-- early, late show. You do 14 shows, basically. And I bombed all 14 shows. And, in between the shows, I didn't know what to do, because I'm not a huge drinker. I don't really gamble. And so, the first night, I decided to go back to my hotel room that was so far away from the venue that I only had enough time to just stand still like this for two minutes, and then walk back to the venue.
我在拉斯维加斯演出。在拉斯维加斯演出时，你要做一周的表演。每晚有两场演出——早期场和晚场。基本上一共要做14场演出。我14场全砸了。演出间隙，我不知道该做什么，因为我不怎么喝酒。我也不怎么赌博。所以第一天晚上，我决定回酒店房间，离场地太远了，导致我只有足够的时间像这样站着呆两分钟，然后又走回场地。
So, after that first night, I decided that I would spend the evening-- in between the early and late show, I'd sit in the back corner of the venue, just have a glass of water while they're cleaning the table tops and vacuuming, getting ready for the late show. I did that every night for the rest of the week. And, the last night of the week, my phone rang. And it was my agent calling to tell me that the venue had called him to say that they thought it was weird that I was just sitting in the back corner, and could I please go find something else to do. Do you know how humiliating that was? So humiliating-- because you know that call didn't come from some far away headquarters somewhere. It came from someone in that venue, looking through some little window, just like, yeah, tell her to get out of here. I'm sick of looking at her face.
所以第一晚之后，我决定在演出间隙把晚上打发掉——我会坐在场地后排的角落里，在他们清理桌子和吸尘、为晚场做准备时，只喝一杯水。那一周余下的日子里，我每天都这么做。那周的最后一天，我的电话响了。是我经纪人打来的，说场地打电话告诉他，他们觉得我坐在后排角落很奇怪，能不能请我去找点别的事做。你知道那有多丢人吗？太丢人了——因为你知道那通电话不是来自什么遥远的总部。而是来自场地里的某个人，透过窗户往外看，就像是：“行了，让她滚，我烦透了看她那张脸。”
So, again, I didn't know where to go or what to do. So I took the escalator down to the first floor, and there was an ice cream parlor-- or, I don't know, are they called ice cream parlors? You know, take me to the ice cream parlor. I mean, I'm eight years from 50. I don't just sit and have ice cream by myself just like-- and let me be sure to not use my microphone, which is the exact shape of an ice cream cone.
所以，同样，我不知道去哪儿做什么。于是我搭电梯到了底楼，那里有个冰淇淋店——或者，我不知道，那叫冰淇淋店吗？你知道的，带我去冰淇淋店吧。我是说，我离50岁还有8年。我不能就这样一个人坐着吃冰淇淋——而且，我要确保别用我的麦克风，它形状和冰淇淋蛋筒一模一样。
So I have my ice cream. And I finish my ice cream. I go back up the escalator to the venue. And I do my final show of the week. And I bomb. I get offstage. I shake hands with the audience members. They're just looking at me like, we hate you. I'm just like, feeling is mutual. I shook hands with the other comedians on the show. And they were just like, we cannot stand you. I was like, OK, top hat comedian, you're right. I'm horrible.
所以我吃了冰淇淋。吃完后，我乘电梯回到场地。然后我完成了这周最后一场演出。结果还是砸了。我下了台。我和观众握手。他们看我的眼神就像：我们讨厌你。我感觉：彼此彼此。我和表演的其他喜剧演员握手。他们就像：我们受不了你。我说：行，顶级帽子喜剧演员，你是对的。我真烂。
But I went, got paid in the office. And I went back to my hotel room. I put on my pajamas, little pants that had little pigs flying all over them. I looked adorable. It was my one small victory of the week. Then I went in to brush my tooth. And that is when I caught my reflection in the mirror and saw that I had a full-blown chocolate mustache on [INAUDIBLE]. No!
但我去办公室领了钱。然后回到了酒店房间。我穿上睡衣，那是印满小飞猪图案的裤子。我看起来可爱极了。那是那一周我唯一的小胜利。然后我走进厕所刷牙。就在那一刻，我瞥见镜子里的自己，看到满脸都是巧克力胡子……不！
My brain completely replaying everything that evening-- I'm on stage bombing for one hour with a full-blown chocolate mustache on my face. And then I'm very face to face, intimately shaking hands with the audience members. Nobody was like, oh, you have-- no-- just hating me-- shaking hands with the other comedians. Then I go get paid by the guy that I am certain was who made the original phone call telling me to get out of there and find something else to do. Guess who found something else to do? Yeah, me. I went and had a little bit of ice cream for myself. What was he thinking when I was sitting there in that office with him, a full-grown woman with a full-blown chocolate mustache on my face?
我的大脑完全在回放那天晚上的每一件事——我在台上演了一个小时，脸上带着一撇巨大的巧克力胡子。然后我非常亲密地面对面地与观众握手。没有人像：噢，你脸上……没有——只是讨厌我——和演员们握手。然后那个我确信是打电话让我滚蛋的人给我发了工资。猜猜谁去找了别的事做？没错，是我。我去吃了点冰淇淋。当我和他坐在那间办公室里时，他怎么想？一个成年女性，脸上带着一撇巨大的巧克力胡子？
You know, could I not just glance in the mirror before I get on stage? What is my checklist before a show? Belly full of ice cream, check-- head on stage What did he-- did he think I had put on a fake mustache to sneak back into the venue he had kicked me out of? Just hopped on stage-- not so funny anymore, is it, Vegas? They're just like, we never thought you were.
你知道，在上台前我难道不能看一眼镜子吗？演出前的检查清单是什么？肚子填满冰淇淋，勾选——上台。他怎么想——他以为我贴了假胡子来潜回我被赶出的场地吗？只是蹦上台——在拉斯维加斯，这可不那么好笑了，对吧？他们只是觉得：我们从来就觉得你不搞笑。
Tig Notaro-- that story is part of the material she's working up for her first HBO comedy special. It's called "Tig Notaro, Boyish Girl Interrupted." It airs in August, on Saturday, August 22nd, 10:00 Eastern, exclusively on HBO. Her tour  schedule is at TigNation.com. Coming up, people who never, ever can actually have a game face, like their bodies prevent that from happening biologically. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
蒂格·诺塔罗——那个故事是她为第一个HBO喜剧特辑准备的素材。它叫《蒂格·诺塔罗：男孩气女孩的告解》。它将在8月播出，8月22日星期六，美东时间10点，HBO独家播出。她的巡演日程在 TigNation.com。接下来，那些永远、永远无法保持“扑克脸”的人，就像他们的身体生物学上就阻止了这种事情发生。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's "This American Life." I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show-- game face.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，带给你们关于那个主题的各种故事。今天的节目——“扑克脸”。
My entire adult life, I've never used the expression game face. I have no [BLEEP] idea what it means or what you're supposed to--
在我整个成年生活中，我从来没用过“扑克脸”这个表达。我根本不知道那是什么意思，或者你应该……
That's legendary Indiana basketball coach Bobby Knight back in a 1992 press conference. And, after he says that he doesn't know what a game face is supposed to be, he makes a series of fake, intense faces-- scowls and grimaces-- ridiculing the idea of a game face.
那是传奇印第安纳篮球教练鲍比·奈特在1992年新闻发布会上的片段。而且，在他说了他不知道“扑克脸”应该是什么样子之后，他做了一系列虚假的、激烈的表情——怒视和苦笑——嘲讽了“扑克脸”的概念。
The biggest regret of my life is not asking a question that Bobby Knight ever got mad at in a press conference.
我这辈子最大的遗憾就是没能在新闻发布会上问一个鲍比·奈特曾经发过火的问题。
That's Mike Pesca, one of the hosts of the sports podcast "Hang Up and Listen," also the host of the daily podcast "The Gist with Mike Pesca." He's the person who told me about the apparently very famous Bobby Knight quote about game face.
那是迈克·佩斯卡，体育播客《Hang Up and Listen》的主持人之一，也是每日播客《The Gist with Mike Pesca》的主持人。他就是告诉我鲍比·奈特那段非常著名的关于“扑克脸”名言的人。
He meant it to say it's a ridiculous notion that real athletes don't have. And what I feel--
他的意思是这是一种真正运动员不会有的荒谬概念。而我的感觉……
Because his attitude was just, like, we're out there doing our jobs. we're intense people doing a job. We're not putting on a mask.
因为他的态度就是：我们只是在那里做我们的工作。我们是努力做着工作的热血之人。我们不是戴着面具。
That's right. And, as I think about it, Bobby Knight was like that all the time. And so a lot of these guys-- not everyone, but a lot of these guys-- they don't have game face. That's what they live. If you're an intense, competitive person, that's how you live.
没错。仔细想想，鲍比·奈特一直都是那样。所以很多人——不是所有人，但很多人——他们没有“扑克脸”。那就是他们的生活方式。如果你是个激烈、好胜的人，那就是你的生活方式。
The fact is, though, not all athletes feel the way that Bobby Knight did about this. Some of them consciously cultivate their game faces, Pesca says. They talk about wanting to intimidate.
事实上，并非所有运动员都像鲍比·奈特那样看待这个问题。佩斯卡说，有些人有意识地培养他们的“扑克脸”。他们谈论想要震慑对手。
So Dennis Eckersley, a great relief pitcher-- he had a long, flowing black mustache. And he would talk about his own self-image as Black Bart, as a bad cowboy who came to town. And he was going to mow down the opposition. Randy Johnson, who is an extremely tall major league pitcher, would lean out over the mound. And he had a scowl on his face. And I also think there is a classic predator and prey situation. You know, in nature, predators have their eyes closer to their nose. Prey have their eyes on either side. And I think, when Randy Johnson is scowling at you, you feel fear.
比如丹尼斯·埃克斯利，一位伟大的救援投手——他留着长长的黑胡子。他会谈论自己作为“黑巴特”的形象，作为一个进城的坏牛仔。他打算扫荡对手。兰迪·约翰逊，一位极高的职棒大联盟投手，会向土丘上方倾斜。他脸上带着怒视。我也认为这是一个典型的掠食者与猎物的情况。在自然界中，掠食者的眼睛离鼻子更近。猎物的眼睛在两侧。我认为，当兰迪·约翰逊怒视你时，你会感到恐惧。
Other players with great game faces that Mike pointed to-- Bob Gibson from the Cardinals, Roger Clemens, John Starks and Charles Oakley of the Knicks, Dan Marino of the Miami Dolphins, Mike Singletary of the Chicago Bears. When it comes to the player with the greatest game face in sports, the game faciest game face, we went on a search. And we believe that it is none of those guys. We nominate a hockey player, an old school guy.
迈克指出的其他拥有精彩“扑克脸”的球员——红雀队的鲍勃·吉布森、罗杰·克莱门斯、尼克斯队的约翰·斯塔克斯和查尔斯·奥克利、迈阿密海豚队的丹·马里诺、芝加哥熊队的迈克·辛格莱特里。当谈到体育界拥有最强“扑克脸”、最“扑克脸”的球员时，我们进行了一番搜索。我们认为不是这些人。我们提名一位冰球运动员，一位老派球员。
So, in this week's show, we're going to make the case for Terry Sawchuk.
所以，在本周的节目中，我们将为特里·索楚克提出辩护。
Good case-- sad case.
很好的案例——悲伤的案例。
Why sad?
为什么悲伤？
Terry Sawchuk played-- he was one of the best goalies in NHL history. And he played in an era-- a benighted era-- where it was all about toughness. And we can't believe this, but goalies didn't wear masks. The game wasn't any different. The puck wasn't any softer, just goalies didn't wear masks.
特里·索楚克是NHL历史上最伟大的守门员之一。但他身处一个时代——一个蒙昧的时代——那时一切都讲究硬度。我们简直不敢相信，但守门员当时不戴面具。比赛并没有什么不同。冰球并没有变软，只是守门员不戴面具。
So there were no protective masks. And Sawchuk was this relentless guy who won four Stanley cups and was injured so many times that, at some point, Life Magazine did this photo of his face where a makeup artist and a doctor basically just recreated all the scars and all the places that he had been stitched up. And when you see it, he looks like Frankenstein. It's hard to see it and not think Frankenstein. And his face took so many of these injuries because of something that Sawchuk is famous for inventing, a way of being a goalie that actually took his unmasked face and put it directly into the line of fire.
所以没有保护面具。索楚克是个无情的家伙，赢得了四次斯坦利杯，受过无数次伤，以至于在某个时刻，《生活》杂志拍了一张他脸部的照片，化妆师和医生基本上复原了他所有的伤疤和缝针处。当你看到那张图时，他看起来像科学怪人。很难看一眼而不想到科学怪人。他的脸承受了这么多伤，是因为索楚克发明了一种闻名于世的守门方式，那种方式实际上把他的面部直接置于火线之中。
Before Terry came along in 1950 in the NHL, goalies tended to stand and bend a little wee bit at the knee.
在特里1950年进入NHL之前，守门员倾向于站立并稍微弯曲膝盖。
That's David Dupuis, who wrote a biography of Terry Sawchuk. He says that stance meant the goalie's head was higher than the top of the goal. But Sawchuk bent over. He bent over at the middle. If you've watched a professional hockey game in the last, like, half a century, pretty much any goalie you see is imitating Sawchuk.
那是大卫·杜普伊斯，他写了特里·索楚克的传记。他说那种姿势意味着守门员的头比球门顶部高。但索楚克弯下腰。他从中间弯下去。如果你在过去半个世纪看过专业冰球比赛，你看到的几乎所有守门员都在模仿索楚克。
His back is almost flat. I mean--
他的背几乎是平的。我是说……
It's almost like parallel to thee ice.
简直平行于冰面。
Almost parallel to the ice. His wife Pat used to tell him that she thought she could put a cup of coffee on his back, and it wouldn't get spilled. And his face would be low, creating a great sense of gravity, helped him to move laterally. But it put his face directly-- almost the first thing in line with the puck. It was a great show of courage, but it tended to help his getting 600 facial stitches.
简直平行于冰面。他的妻子帕特曾告诉他，她觉得可以把一杯咖啡放在他的背上，而且不会洒出来。他的脸会很低，创造出一种伟大的重力感，帮助他横向移动。但这使他的脸直接处于冰球的射程内。这展现了巨大的勇气，但也导致他脸部被缝了600针。
Yeah, how often was he hit by the puck? How often was his face hit?
是啊，他多久会被冰球击中一次？他的脸多久被击中一次？
Well, 600 facial stitches-- I would guess probably maybe 20 times a season, sometimes excessive enough that-- remember the Red Wing doctor, Dr. John Finley, telling me that one time Terry had been hit in the nose so severely that the front cartilage was tore, almost hanging by a thread.
嗯，面部缝了600针——我猜可能每赛季20次吧，有时过于频繁，以至于……记得红翼队的医生约翰·芬利医生告诉我，有一次特里的鼻子被击中得非常严重，前软骨被撕裂，几乎悬挂着。
That is, half his nose almost came off his face.
也就是说，他半个鼻子几乎掉下来了。
And he stitched it back on. And I remember him saying that you or I, in our profession, or any profession, would be sidelined for weeks. He sutured Terry up, and Terry went right back out and played the rest of the game.
然后他把它缝了回去。我记得他说，如果是你我，在我们的行业，或任何行业，都会休战几周。他给特里缝好，特里直接回到场上打完了余下的比赛。
All set to go now, Stankowski with [INAUDIBLE]
现在准备好了，斯坦科夫斯基带着……
Here's a not unusual day at work for Sawchuk, a playoff game from 1967 against the Chicago Blackhawks.
这是索楚克工作日的常态，一场1967年对阵芝加哥黑鹰队的季后赛。
[INAUDIBLE] to Bobby Howe. There's the shot. Oh, and Sawchuk was hit and knocked flat. Terry Sawchuk took that tremendous blast off the stick of Bobby Hull-- boom, down goes Sawchuk. What a tremendous shot from short range. The way he went down, Bill, it-- well, we watch him get up now. Get a good look at Terry Sawchuk. He's got bruises all over his body from other shots taken in this series. Watching him in the dressing room the other night, one shoulder was yellow, and blue, and orange-- every color in the rainbow, it appeared. And it was that same left shoulder.
……传给鲍比·豪。射门！哦，索楚克被击中，平躺在地上。特里·索楚克承受了鲍比·赫尔那一记巨大的重击——砰，索楚克倒下了。真是精彩的短距离射门。比尔，看他倒下的方式……好吧，我们现在看着他起来。好好看看特里·索楚克。他在这个系列赛中被击中，全身都是淤青。前几天在更衣室看他，一个肩膀是黄、蓝、橙色的——似乎彩虹上的每种颜色都有。而且是同一个左肩。
Off the ice, Sawchuk's life was pretty tragic. Dupuis talked to people close to him, and he says that  Sawchuk was an alcoholic for his whole career, mentally abusive to his kids and wife, a vicious drunk who would rant, and rave, and throw things. He died at 40 from medical complications that he got after a fight with a teammate. The fight was over nothing-- some bills, Dupuis says. I mean, that's what it started as, anyway. It began at the bar and continued at their rented house.
场外，索楚克的生活相当悲惨。杜普伊斯采访了了解他的人，他说索楚克整个职业生涯都是酒鬼，对孩子和妻子进行精神虐待，一个酗酒如命的醉鬼，会咆哮、狂怒和扔东西。他40岁时因与队友打架后引发的医疗并发症去世。打架没什么原因——就是一些账单，杜普伊斯说。我是说，不管怎样，起因就是这样。是在酒吧开始的，在他们的租赁房子里继续。
They're swinging at each other, and Terry falls on a part of a barbecue. And then he realizes he's badly hurt. He's got an injury to his abdomen.
他们互相挥拳，然后特里摔在了烧烤架上。然后他意识到自己伤得很重。他腹部受了伤。
It just seems so-- I don't know, so--
这看起来太……我不知道，太……
Senseless?
荒唐？
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, it's senseless.
是的，太荒唐了。
You know, the whole idea of a game face implies that somebody's putting it on, like they're putting on like-- you know, like they're acting. But with him, do you feel like he was ever acting on the ice?
你知道，“扑克脸”的概念暗示着有人在装，就像在……你知道，就像在演戏一样。但对他，你觉得他在冰上装过吗？
No. No, never. What you saw is what you got. He was intense. There's no doubt about it. He was intense. And it's funny. Sometimes, before a game, he would look to a teammate and said, hey boys, I only need two tonight. And they would end up winning the game 2-1.
不，不，绝对没有。你看到的就是你得到的。他很激烈。毫无疑问。他很激烈。而且很有趣。有时，在比赛前，他会看着队友说：“嘿伙计们，今晚我只需要两个。”他们最终会以2比1赢得比赛。
All right, in other words, you just need to score two points, and we'll win.
好了，换句话说，你只需要得两分，我们就会赢。
Yep, two goals-- just get me two goals, and we're going to win this thing.
对，两个进球——只要给我两个进球，我们就能赢下比赛。
In 1962, Sawchuk decided to start wearing a goalie's mask. Barely any goalies were doing it back then. But he was so tough, Dupuis says, everybody else felt like it was now OK for them to start as well. And they did. Since then, hockey goalies don't put their faces in direct danger the same way Sawchuk did. So none of them can come close to the game faciest game face in the sport.
1962年，索楚克决定开始戴守门员面具。那时候几乎没有守门员这样做。但他太强悍了，杜普伊斯说，其他人都觉得既然他都戴了，那他们也可以开始戴。于是他们就照做了。从那时起，冰球守门员不再像索楚克那样把脸直接置于危险之中。所以没有人的“扑克脸”能接近这项运动中那个最“扑克脸”的“扑克脸”。
[MUSIC - "U DON'T KNOW" BY JAY-Z]
[音乐 - Jay-Z 演唱的《U Don't Know》]
Act 4, "Frankly, Miss Scarlett." so a few weeks ago, at a story meeting, everybody here at the radio show-- we were sitting around talking about this week's episode and what game face is all about. And one of people who works here, Elna Baker, raised the whole idea of blushing, how blushing is the opposite of game face. The world sees exactly what you're thinking and what you're feeling, especially for people who blush a lot. In fact, there's a whole kind of blushing that's known as chronic or pathological blushing. And there are medical papers about this. There are online forums. People who blush many times each day-- basically, they have an overactive nervous system. Their blushing mechanism is on a hair trigger.
第四幕，“坦白说，斯嘉丽小姐。”几周前，在故事会上，广播节目的每个人——我们坐在那讨论这周的剧集以及什么是“扑克脸”。其中一位同事埃尔娜·贝克提出了脸红的概念，脸红是“扑克脸”的对立面。世界能看透你在想什么和感受什么，尤其是对于那些经常脸红的人。事实上，有一种脸红被称为慢性或病理性脸红。医学期刊上有相关的文献。网上也有论坛。每天脸红多次的人——基本上，他们有一个过度活跃的神经系统。他们的脸红机制非常敏感。
So anyway, sitting there talking about all this. And finally Elna said she has it. And a bunch of use are like, wait, you have it? At which point Elna-- she didn't say anything. She unwraps this black scarf that she'd been wearing on her neck. And, you know, the skin right below her neck-- they were just covered with red blotches. Now I've known Elna for like five or six years and, until this moment, it never occurred to me that, like a person who's been bitten by a vampire in a bad movie, Elna is always wearing a scarf or a turtleneck.
总之，坐在那讨论这一切。最后埃尔娜说她有这种情况。我们一堆人就像：等等，你有？就在这时，埃尔娜——她什么也没说。她解开了脖子上戴的黑色围巾。而且，你知道，她脖子下面的皮肤——上面布满了红斑。我认识埃尔娜大概五六年了，直到那一刻，我才意识到，就像坏电影里被吸血鬼咬过的人一样，埃尔娜总是戴着围巾或高领毛衣。
And Elna told all of us she'd been thinking about getting surgery. Yes, there's surgery which can make you stop blushing. And she'd been talking about it with friends. And she'd even made an appointment to consult with a doctor about it, at which point another producer on staff, Sean Cole, said he'd researched the surgery for a story that he never ended up doing years ago. And he remembered that it had these possible serious side effects. And he wondered, was Elna really seriously considering this? And he said, if she was, he could help her research whether this was a good idea or not and decided she should do it. And so, with that in mind, Sean has this report.
埃尔娜告诉我们大家她一直在考虑动手术。没错，有种手术可以让你停止脸红。她和朋友们讨论过。她甚至预约了医生进行咨询，此时员工里的另一位制片人肖恩·科尔说，他几年前为了一个没做成的故事研究过这个手术。他记得这有潜在的严重副作用。他想知道埃尔娜是否真的在认真考虑这个？他说，如果她在考虑，他可以帮她研究这是否是个好主意，决定她是否该做。所以带着这个想法，肖恩有了这个报道。
So the first thing you need to understand about Elna's blushing is that it's not really what you think of when you think of blushing. She doesn't go red in the face all of a sudden when something embarrassing happens. Instead, the redness comes on slowly, starting on her chest, and working its way up her neck to her face and ears. And it can catch her by surprise sometimes.
所以关于埃尔娜的脸红，首先你要明白，它不是你脸红时想到的那种。她不会在尴尬事情发生时突然脸红。相反，红色是慢慢出现的，从胸口开始，蔓延到脖子，再到脸和耳朵。有时会让她措手不及。
Like it just happened yesterday in the shower.
就像昨天洗澡时刚发生的那样。
In the shower?
在洗澡时？
Yeah, I was showering. And I looked down. I'm like, why am I broken into hives? Or not hives-- I have to stop calling it that.
是啊，我在洗澡。然后我低头看。我在想：为什么我起荨麻疹了？或者不是荨麻疹——我得停止那么叫它。
But they're hive-like.
但这确实像荨麻疹。
Hive-like red splotches-- you can really see it, because the splotches almost look like countries all over me as they grow.
像荨麻疹一样的红斑——你能清楚地看到它，因为那些斑块在生长时看起来就像我身上布满了各个国家。
You're like a map of the world.
你就像一张世界地图。
Yes.
是的。
But does it seem like it's like a social-- you're checking your chest to see if it's happening now.
但这看起来像是某种社交……你正在检查自己的胸口看现在是不是发生了。
That's the one that I said was the-- like, when that one starts--
这就是我说的那个……当那个开始时……
Oh, that's the canary in the coal mine one.
噢，那是“矿井里的金丝雀”。
Yeah, that's the trigger one.
对，那是触发点。
Wow, it always starts with one particular part of your chest.
哇，它总是从你胸口某个特定部位开始。
Yep.
对。
And it's just because you're talking about it.
而且那只是因为你在谈论它。
Mhm.
嗯。
This has caused a real problem in terms of Elna's job. She only works on our show for part of the week. A lot of her life involves being on stage. She's made appearances at the storytelling show "The Moth." She's gone on tours with "The Moth." She auditions for commercials and other acting gigs, and sometimes gets those parts.
这在埃尔娜的工作方面造成了真正的问题。她每周只在我们节目工作一部分时间。她生活的大部分涉及登台表演。她在故事讲述节目《The Moth》中亮相。她随《The Moth》巡演。她试镜广告和其他表演工作，有时也会得到这些角色。
So I'm heading into my show.
所以我要去参加演出了。
I asked her to record herself as she went around during the day, to see how much she blushes. And here she's just arriving at a storytelling event.
我请她记录下一天中到处走动时的感受，看看她脸红得有多频繁。这里她刚抵达一个讲故事的活动现场。
And, in anticipation, on the subway, I already broke into hives, so I am arriving with hives on my chest already, because I'm nervous that I'm going to break into hives when I perform, because I will.
而且，在期待中，在地铁上，我就已经起疹子了，所以我到达时胸口已经有了疹子，因为我紧张自己表演时会起疹子，因为我确实会。
Now there's a name for the thought process Elna just described, and it's a word I love-- erythrophobia. It literally means fear of the color red, but it can also mean fear of blushing. That is, you worry you're going to blush. And then the worry makes you blush. And then you're embarrassed that you're blushing, and so you blush harder, and so on.
现在有一个名字来形容埃尔娜描述的思维过程，我喜欢这个词——“赤色恐惧症”。它字面意思是害怕红色，但也可以指害怕脸红。也就是说，你担心自己会脸红。然后这种担心让你脸红。然后你因为脸红而尴尬，所以你脸红得更厉害，以此类推。
I wish that you didn't have to know how I was feeling, like you didn't have to see it. I have a tell. I have a huge tell all over me, and I'm wearing it all the time.
我希望你不需要知道我的感受，就像你不需要看到它一样。我有某种信号。我全身都有个巨大的信号，而且我一直戴着它。
When you research this condition, you can find stories of people going to extreme measures to hide their blushing. I heard about more than one blusher who deliberately got a sunburn before having to make a presentation. One woman would only agree to meet people in bars where the lights were red. Another, who was planning her wedding, visited 60 churches looking for the one with the shortest distance between the curb and the front door, so the fewest number of strangers would see her walking in in her dress. Yet another blusher, who was an engineer, carried around this electrical device he built himself and would shock himself to try to keep from turning red. And it didn't work.
当你研究这种情况时，你会发现人们为了掩盖脸红采取极端措施的故事。我听说不止一个脸红者在做演讲前故意晒伤自己。一位女士只同意在灯光是红色的酒吧里见人。另一位筹备婚礼的人参观了60座教堂，寻找路边到前门距离最短的一座，这样就不会有太多陌生人看到她穿着婚纱走进来。还有一位脸红者，是个工程师，随身带着他自己制造的电气装置，会电击自己试图保持不脸红。但没用。
Many chronic blushers will go out of their way to avoid people. They withdraw. Some develop serious depression. And a few years ago-- you might have read about this in the news-- there was a student at the University of Washington in Seattle who felt tortured by his blushing. His dorm room was on the 11th floor, but he always took the stairs so that he didn't have to risk blushing in front of people in the elevator. Finally, one day, he wrote a five-page letter to his family and threw himself off the 11th floor balcony. In the letter, he said, quote, it's exhausting to wake up every day and have to find little ways to avoid blushing situations.
许多慢性脸红者会不惜一切代价避开人。他们退缩。有些人患上严重的抑郁症。几年前——你可能在新闻里读到过——西雅图华盛顿大学有一名学生被脸红折磨。他的宿舍在11楼，但他总是走楼梯，这样他就不用冒着在电梯里人前脸红的风险。最后，有一天，他给家人写了一封五页的信，然后从11楼的阳台跳了下去。在信中他说，引用他的话：“每天醒来都要想方设法避开可能脸红的场合，这真是太累人了。”
Elna blushes about three or four times a day. It used to be less, but something happened about a year and a half ago that made the problem a lot worse. She was auditioning for a sitcom, a very big role, and a role that mirrored her life in a lot of ways. She really wanted the part. The producers really wanted her to have the part. And it mattered so much to her that she threw all of her will into not blushing. She repeated to herself, over and over, you're not going to blush. You're not going to blush. You can probably guess what happened. The head of the network watched Elna's test and said she looked too nervous on camera. She says, after that happened, she sort of threw up her hands.
埃尔娜大约每天脸红三到四次。过去频率更低，但大约一年半前发生了一些事，让问题变得严重得多。她正在为一个情景喜剧试镜，一个非常重要的角色，一个在很多方面映射了她生活的角色。她非常想要这个角色。制片人也非常希望她得到那个角色。这事对她太重要了，她把所有的意志都投入到“不脸红”上。她反复对自己说：你不会脸红。你不会脸红。你可能猜到发生了什么。网络主管观看了埃尔娜的测试，说她在镜头前看起来太紧张了。她说，那件事发生后，她就放弃了。
And now it happens all the time.
现在它一直发生。
Oh, so that was a moment where you felt like it had won.
噢，所以那是一个你觉得它赢了的时刻。
It won, yeah. But then it also makes me think the only way to fix it is to get this surgery.
它赢了，是的。但这也让我觉得唯一的解决办法就是动这个手术。
So the surgery-- Elna's been weighing the pros and cons of it for a while. And I wanted to see if I could help her land on one side or the other. The operation itself has another name I love. It's called an endoscopic thoracic sympathectomy, or ETS. That is, they tunnel a little camera, a scope, through small incisions in your upper torso or thorax, thoracic, and they cut out your sympathy. I'm kidding. They burn out part of what's called your sympathetic nerve on both sides of your body. It's responsible for blushing and also sweating in your face and hands. It was actually pioneered to cure excessively sweaty palms. And then they figured out it works for blushing, too.
所以手术——埃尔娜一直在衡量利弊。我想看看能不能帮她定论。手术本身有另一个我喜欢的名字。它叫“内窥镜胸交感神经切断术”，或 ETS。也就是说，他们通过你上半身或胸腔的小切口插入一个小摄像头，即胸腔镜，然后切除你的“同情心”。开玩笑的。他们烧掉身体两侧所谓的交感神经的一部分。它负责面部和手部的脸红和出汗。它最初实际上是为了治愈多汗手心而首创的。后来他们发现它对脸红也有效。
So what have you thought-- like, what is the conversation in your head about the surgery?
所以你考虑过……你脑子里关于手术的想法是什么？
I want to get it. I think the only thing is I don't want a droopy eye.
我想做。唯一的问题是我不想要眼睑下垂。
That's one of the potential side effects. Your eyelid hangs kind of low. It's also called Horner's syndrome, but it's pretty rare.
那是潜在副作用之一。你的眼睑会垂下来。这也叫“霍纳综合征”，但非常罕见。
The doctor told me that there was a 1% probability of me developing the Horner's syndrome.
医生告诉我，我有1%的概率发展成霍纳综合征。
I talked with a few people who actually had the surgery, to see how it worked out for them, starting with this guy, Enrique Jadresic.
我和一些真正做过手术的人聊过，看看效果如何，从这个家伙——恩里克·贾德雷西奇开始。
I am a former chronic blusher. And the other thing, which I find interesting, is that I am a doctor.
我是一个前慢性脸红者。还有一件事我觉得很有趣，那就是我是一名医生。
He's a psychiatrist in Santiago, Chile. He now treats other blushers in his practice. And he also wrote one of very few books you can find about the condition, part of which is about his own struggles with the problem. He told me about this one time he was teaching at his university. And, out of nowhere-- he doesn't remember why-- he turned red in the face. And a student, who was maybe 22 years old, looked up at him and said, oh professor, you've gone into the cherry tree again, which I guess sounds better in Spanish.
他是圣地亚哥的一名精神科医生。他现在在诊所里治疗其他脸红者。他还写了关于这种疾病极少数书籍中的一本，其中一部分就是关于他自己与该问题的斗争。他告诉我，有一次他在大学教学。莫名其妙地——他不记得为什么——他满脸通红。一个大概22岁的学生抬头看着他说：“噢教授，你又进樱桃树林了。”我猜在西班牙语里听起来比这好听。
And that was awful. I mean, for me who-- I was an authority, you see?
那真是太糟糕了。我是说，对我来说——我是权威，你明白吗？
Yeah.
嗯。
I was supposed to be the one who knew everything, you see?
我本应该是那个无所不知的人，你明白吗？
The cherry tree.
樱桃树林。
That's very uncomfortable.
那真是太不舒服了。
Every time Dr. Jadresic was out and about, he was constantly looking around for people he knew, worried that someone might come up out of nowhere and say hello, which would make him blush. It was exhausting. And then he was asked to run for president of this big Chilean psychiatric and neurology society. It was the equivalent of Elna's TV audition. But he hesitated, because he knew he'd have to travel and make appearances in front of people. It was around that time that he read about the surgery in a Chilean newspaper. And, about two months after he had the operation--
贾德雷西奇医生每次出门在外，都在不停地寻找认识的人，担心有人会突然冒出来打招呼，那会让他脸红。这太累人了。然后他被要求竞选智利精神病学和神经病学学会的主席。这相当于埃尔娜的电视试镜。但他犹豫了，因为他知道他必须出差并在人前露面。就在那时，他在一份智利报纸上读到了这个手术。而且，在他动完手术大约两个月后——
I went to a pharmacy. And the lady who was selling at the pharmacy said, oh Dr. Jadresic, how are you? And everybody turned to me to see me. And she said-- and she would speak very loudly. I don't know why. But she would speak very loudly. And she said, oh Dr. Jadresic, are you still considered one of the most handsome mens at the teaching hospital where I knew you? And I couldn't believe it, but I didn't blush.
我去了一家药店。在那儿卖药的女士说：“噢，贾德雷西奇医生，你好吗？”每个人都转过来看我。她说——她说话声音非常大。我不知道为什么。但她说话声音特别大。她说：“噢，贾德雷西奇医生，你还被认为是我认识的教学医院里最帅的男人之一吗？”我简直不敢相信，但我没脸红。
Wow.
哇。
And that told me, of course, that the operation had been successful.
那告诉我，手术确实成功了。
Since then, Dr. Jadresic has become something of an expert on blushers and blushing. He's seen about 800 blushers in his practice, read up on different theories as to why we blush. Charles Darwin wrote a whole chapter on blushing in his book, "The Expression of Emotions in Man and Animals." He starts off, quote, "Blushing is the most peculiar and most human of all expressions." So no other animal does it. Dr. Jadresic and other people in his field think maybe people blush to signal to the group, I know I screwed up. Don't attack me. So it's a protective measure. Blushers are very respectful of others, Jadresic says-- very nice people, overall.
从那时起，贾德雷西奇医生已经成了脸红和脸红者的专家。他在诊所里见过大约800名脸红者，阅读了关于我们为什么会脸红的不同理论。查尔斯·达尔文在他的著作《人类与动物的情绪表达》中用一整章讨论了脸红。他开头引用：“脸红是所有表情中最独特、最人类的表现。”所以没有其他动物会这样。贾德雷西奇医生和该领域的其他人认为，也许人们脸红是为了向群体发出信号：我知道我搞砸了。别攻击我。所以这是一种防御措施。脸红者非常尊重他人，贾德雷西奇说——总体来说是非常好的人。
People who blush are very empathic. They put themselves in the pants of people in front of them.
会脸红的人非常有同理心。他们会换位思考，站在对方的立场上。
In the pants--
站在立场上……
And you know, in psychiatry, the opposite-- the complete opposite-- would be the psychopath. Psychopaths never blush.
而且你知道，在精神病学中，对立面——完全的对立面——是精神病患者。精神病患者从不脸红。
The empathy thing is certainly true of Elna.
同理心这点在埃尔娜身上确实是真的。
I could be watching a TV show, and something happens to someone on the show. And I'll look down, and I'll be blushing on behalf of this embarrassing thing that happened to a person on the screen.
我会看电视节目，节目里某人发生了什么事。我低头看，我会替屏幕上的人感到脸红，替那个丢人的事感到脸红。
I mean, that seems like a really nice quality.
我是说，那看起来真是个很好的品质。
But maybe I care too much. Maybe it would be good to have the edge taken off.
但也许我太在意了。也许能减轻一点压力会很好。
Dr. Jadresic didn't develop Horner's syndrome, the droopy eye. But he does have to cope with a really common side effect of the sympathectomy. He doesn't sweat from his head or his hands. The operation cuts off the sweat response in those two places. So your body compensates by sweating in weirder places, like your chest, back, groin, and feet. Dr. Jadresic says you especially need to bear that in mind if you live in a hot climate. Elna was unfazed.
贾德雷西奇医生没有发展出霍纳综合征，即眼睑下垂。但他确实必须应对交感神经切断术的一个非常普遍的副作用。他的头部或手部不出汗。手术切断了这两个地方的出汗反应。所以你的身体会通过在更奇怪的地方出汗来补偿，比如你的胸口、背部、腹股沟和脚。贾德雷西奇医生说，如果你生活在炎热的气候中，特别需要记住这一点。埃尔娜对此无动于衷。
Well I've never been a sweater. I don't have problems with sweating.
嗯，我从不是个爱出汗的人。我没有出汗的问题。
Yet--
暂时……
Yet-- to me it seems easier to hide sweating than blushing.
暂时——对我来说，隐藏出汗似乎比隐藏脸红更容易。
I don't know. I feel like we're underestimating the level of sweating that we're talking about.
我不知道。我觉得我们低估了我们在谈论的出汗程度。
Swamp--
沼泽一样……
The swampy feeling--
那种泥泞的感觉……
But see, I don't care about the feeling. I could feel sweaty. And, as long as you didn't have to know or see, then I could keep faking it. That's the-- this ruins my ability to fake it.
但你看，我不介意那种感觉。我可以觉得出汗。而且，只要你不需要知道或看到，那我就能继续装下去。这就是——这毁了我的装模作样能力。
The surgery can also lower your heart rate which, by most accounts, is not noticeable, unless you're like an Olympic athlete. But this one guy I talked to, who's pretty athletic, likes to run in the morning, says, yeah, he noticed it. And that is by far not the worst thing that happened to him after the surgery. He didn't want his real name used. I'll call him Rich.
手术也会降低你的心率，大多数情况下不明显，除非你是奥运选手。但我谈过的一个人，他挺爱运动，喜欢早晨跑步，说，是的，他注意到了。而且这远不是手术后发生在他身上最糟糕的事情。他不想用真名。我叫他里奇。
Like Elna, he has a "there was a moment when the blushing won" story. He had to give this presentation at school and just couldn't-- physically couldn't. So we high-tailed it out of the building and dropped the course. Not long after that, his father helped him pay for the operation.
和埃尔娜一样，他也有一个“脸红胜出的那一刻”的故事。他必须在学校做演讲，但身体上……做不到。所以我们匆忙离开大楼并退了课。不久之后，他父亲帮他负担了手术费用。
And, after the surgery, I felt like I had a superpower, like I was invincible. I could speak up again. I was in a philosophy class. I argued with the teacher just for the sake of arguing. It was just great. It was a great-- very great while it lasted.
手术后，我觉得我有了超能力，就像我是无敌的。我又可以开口说话了。我在上一门哲学课。我为了争论而和老师争论。这太棒了。这太棒了，持续了一段时间。
Everything was fine for a while. But, about five or six months after the surgery, Rich was at home. And there was a kind of family reunion going on at his house.
一切都好了一阵子。但手术大约五六个月后，里奇在家里。家里正在举办某种家庭聚会。
And my mother hugged me, like in front of a lot of people. And that caused me to become embarrassed. And, out of nowhere, I felt my face turn red again. The problem just came back full force.
我妈妈当着许多人的面拥抱了我。那导致我感到尴尬。莫名其妙地，我感到脸又红了。问题又全力回归了。
Rich isn't sure what happened. He had a different version of the surgery, where they clamp the nerve instead of cutting it. But still, it should have worked. It's possible they didn't clamp the nerve in the right place. There are other cases like this, where the surgery failed, which is another thing I told Elna to keep in mind. In any case, Rich was back at square one and literally thought he was going to lose his mind. And then a psychiatrist prescribed him Prozac.
里奇不确定发生了什么。他做了另一个版本的手术，他们夹住了神经而不是切断它。但即便如此，它也应该有效。有可能他们没有夹在正确的位置。还有其他失败的案例，这也是我告诉埃尔娜要记在心里的另一件事。不管怎样，里奇回到了原点，真的以为自己要疯了。然后精神科医生给他开了百忧解。
It waters you down. It waters me down enough to where I don't have a blushing problem anymore.
它淡化了你。它把我淡化到我不再有脸红问题的程度。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, the Prozac-- that has cured me.
是的，百忧解——治好了我。
I heard from other folks that Prozac can be an effective weapon against blushing, even Dr. Jadresic, whose life was totally improved by the surgery. He says he doesn't really promote the operation to his patients. Rather, he tells them to do a three-month trial of a drug like Prozac first and then decide. And he says six out of 10 patients stick with the medication.
我听说其他人说，百忧解是对抗脸红的有效武器，甚至连贾德雷西奇医生——他的生活因为手术得到了彻底改善——也说他并不真的向患者推销这个手术。相反，他告诉他们先进行三个月的药物试验，比如百忧解，然后再做决定。他说十分之六的患者会坚持服用药物。
I just don't like the idea of medicating myself.
我只是不喜欢给自己吃药的想法。
And why not?
为什么不？
Because it alters my state of mind.
因为它改变了我的精神状态。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
I feel like that's such an American solution. It's like just medicate it away.
我觉得那是一个非常典型的美国解决方案。就像是直接用药物解决。
And surgery is not?
那手术就不是吗？
No, surgery's the best solution ever.
不，手术是最好的解决方案。
I decided I need to talk with someone who had studied the procedure at length. And I found the perfect guy, a surgeon in Sweden named Christer Drott. He says he's performed this operation more than 2,500 times. Not only that, he worked on a long range survey of thousands of people who got sympathectomies for blushing, but also for excessive sweating in the palms and face. They were tracked for almost 15 years and answered questions about how satisfied they were with the surgery and how effective it had been. Overall, about 73% of the blushers were satisfied, which means another 27% were not.
我决定我需要和研究过该程序的人谈谈。我找到了完美的人选，一位瑞典的外科医生叫克里斯特·德罗特。他说他做过2500多次手术。不仅如此，他还对数千名因为脸红、以及因为手心和脸部过度出汗而进行交感神经切断术的人进行了长期跟踪调查。他们被跟踪了近15年，并回答了关于对手术的满意程度以及效果的问题。总的来说，大约73%的脸红者是满意的，这意味着另外27%是不满意的。
Yes, they were either dissatisfied, or even they regretted having the procedure.
是的，他们要么不满意，甚至后悔做了这个手术。
And why?
为什么？
Partly because of the side effects, and partly because of poor effects.
部分是因为副作用，部分是因为效果不佳。
Poor effect-- that it didn't work?
效果不佳——也就是说没用？
Yes. And that, I think, is due to the fact that, in the beginning, we were not aware that we had no effect on the blotchy type on the neck and chest.
是的。而且我认为这归因于这样一个事实：起初我们不知道这种手术对颈部和胸部的斑块型脸红无效。
Wait, you're saying that this operation has no effect on the kind of blushing that's the blotchy type that happens on your chest and neck?
等等，你是说这个手术对那种发生在胸口和脖子上的斑块型脸红无效？
Yes, that's correct. It has only effect on the rapid onset type of blushing in embarrassing situation, the blushing that emerges within seconds.
是的，这是对的。它只对尴尬处境下那种迅速发作的脸红有效，即几秒内出现的脸红。
This is really important, because one of the people that we talked to in this story, my friend Elna-- she has that slowly emerging, blotchy redness. And she's considering getting the surgery, in fact.
这一点非常重要，因为我们在故事中谈到的其中一个人，我的朋友埃尔娜——她就是那种缓慢出现的斑块状潮红。而且事实上，她正在考虑做手术。
I would dissuade her from that.
我会劝阻她。
I broke the news to Elna.
我把这个消息告诉了埃尔娜。
Uh, wow. It's disappointing. But it's good to know. The pro-con list has shifted. Finding out that it won't even work is kind of like, OK.
呃，哇。真令人失望。但这好歹是个好消息。利弊清单变了。发现它根本没用就像是，好吧。
That puts it solidly in the con list.
那把它稳固地放在了弊端清单里。
Solidly in the con list--
稳固地放在弊端清单里……
Yeah.
是啊。
The science around why it wouldn't work for Elna is complicated, to the extent that it's even understood at all. But the best theory is that it isn't Elna's sympathetic nerve that's causing her blushing. It's her adrenal glands. It's adrenaline. Dr. Drott says that's the most likely culprit for the slow onset blotchy blushing. And so these folks tend to blush when they're experiencing stress. It takes more to make them blush than the rapid onset blushers, who can be set off by little things, like bumping into a friend on the street, whereas with Elna, even that time she'd blushed in the shower-- it was stress. She says she was thinking of all the things she had to do that day and getting worked up.
关于为什么对埃尔娜无效的科学道理很复杂。但最好的理论是，导致她脸红的不是交感神经。而是她的肾上腺。是肾上腺素。德罗特医生说那最可能是导致缓慢发作的斑块状脸红的罪魁祸首。所以这些人往往在经历压力时脸红。比起那种会被小事触发的快速发作脸红者，比如在街上撞见朋友，她们需要更多刺激才脸红，而埃尔娜，即便她在那次洗澡时脸红——那也是压力。她说当时她在想那天必须做的所有事，把自己弄得很紧张。
But I think, like, the thing behind the thing is I know it's me.
但我认为，就像，原因背后的原因是我知道是我自己。
What do you mean?
什么意思？
Like I'm doing this.
就像我在做这件事。
So you think there's some amount of agency that maybe you--
所以你认为一定程度上有某种自主权，也许你……
There must be.
肯定有。
Mhm.
嗯哼。
And if I could figure out how not to do it-- like, there must be something that I could think, or do, or--
如果我能找出怎么不去那么做——一定有什么是我能思考、能做，或……
There is something Elna can think and do, according to Dr. Drott, the surgeon. Rather it's something she could not do. It's the simplest thing and possibly more effective than the sympathectomy, or drugs, or anything else.
确实有埃尔娜能思考和能做的事情，据外科医生德罗特医生说。或者说，有什么她能不做的事情。那是这件事最简单、可能比交感神经切断术、药物或任何其他东西更有效的方法。
Some people blush terribly, and they don't care. Oh yes, I've seen the former Norwegian Prime Minister--
有些人脸红得很厉害，但他们不在乎。噢是的，我见过前挪威首相——
That's former Norwegian Prime Minister Gro Harlem Brundtland.
那是前挪威首相格罗·哈莱姆·布伦特兰。
Was blushing like a street lamp-- but she didn't care. She was prime minister anyway.
当时像路灯一样脸红——但她不在乎。她依然是首相。
So you think that, if Elna didn't care as much that she blushed, she would blush less.
所以你认为，如果埃尔娜不在乎她是否脸红，她就会少脸红。
Yes.
是的。
You do think that.
你真的这么认为。
Oh, yes.
噢，是的。
Of course, this is an easy thing to say. When I gave Elna the good doctor's advice, she said-- did you ask him how Elna can not care?
当然，这话容易说。当我把这位好医生的建议告诉埃尔娜时，她说——你问他埃尔娜怎么才能不在乎了吗？
So what do you think you'll do now?
那你现在打算怎么办？
Um, I don't know. I think what I've learned from doing this-- like, I'm not blushing right now.
嗯，我不知道。我觉得我从做这件事中学到的是——我现在没脸红。
I noticed that, actually.
我注意到了，事实上。
That's kind of amazing.
真是太神奇了。
Yeah, it is kind of amazing.
是的，真是太神奇了。
Because I've told people. The fact that now everyone in the meeting knows that I blush, whereas I've been keeping that a secret for 3 and 1/2 years, and wearing turtlenecks, and scarves, and hiding it, if it happens, I think that they'll not judge me. And I feel like that is going to help, too.
因为我告诉了人们。现在会议里的每个人都知道我脸红，而我已经把这个秘密保守了3年半，穿着高领毛衣、戴着围巾隐藏它，如果它真的发生，我想他们不会评判我。我觉得这也会有帮助。
I mean, I don't think any of us would have ever judged you about it in the first place. But now it'll just be like, oh, that's that thing.
我是说，我不觉得我们当中有任何人会因为这件事评判你。但现在这就像是，噢，那就是那件事。
That thing she does.
她做的那件事。
In fact, at the most recent story meeting, Elna showed up without wearing a scarf, and she didn't blush.
事实上，在最近的会议上，埃尔娜没戴围巾就来了，而且她没脸红。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our program.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "POKER FACE" BY ORBA SQUARA]
[音乐 - Orba Squara 演唱的《Poker Face》]
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar and me, with Zoe Chase, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Brian Reed, Robin Semien, Alissa Shipp, Julie Snyder,
and Nancy Updike, editing help from Joel Lovell, production help from Simon Adler. Seth Lind's our Operations Director. Emily Condon's our Production Manager. Elise Bergerson's our Office Manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Research help today from Michelle Harris and Chrispher Swetala. Music help from Damian Gray, from Rob Gettis. Special thanks today to Eric Mennel, Mark Sikes, Christian [INAUDIBLE], Martin Johnson, Stephen Bodson, Paul [? Patsco, ?] Randall [? Maggs, ?] [? Jeff Kline, ?] Stan Fischler, and Jeremy Price. Our website, where you can see that amazing photo from Life Magazine of Terry Sawchuk looking like Frankenstein-- it's really something-- ThisAmericanLive.org. "This American Life" is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who stopped going to the Gap because the customers just act so weird in the dressing room.
好吧，我们今天的节目由乔纳森·门吉瓦和本人制作，佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、斯蒂芬妮·傅、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普、朱莉·斯奈德和南希·厄普代克参与，乔尔·洛弗尔提供编辑帮助，西蒙·阿德勒提供制作帮助。赛斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的办公室经理。埃尔娜·贝克为我们节目搜罗故事。今天的调研帮助来自米歇尔·哈里斯和克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉。音乐帮助来自达米安·格雷、罗布·盖蒂斯。特别感谢埃里克·门内尔、马克·赛克斯、克里斯蒂安、马丁·约翰逊、斯蒂芬·博德森、保罗、兰德尔、杰夫·克莱恩、斯坦·菲什勒和杰里米·普莱斯。我们的网站，在那里你可以看到《生活》杂志那张特里·索楚克看起来像科学怪人的令人惊叹的照片——真的很特别—— ThisAmericanLive.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交流中心 PRX 发送到公共广播电台。一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生，他不再去Gap买衣服，因为那里的顾客在试衣间里表现得太奇怪了。
They put themselves in the pants of people in front of them.
他们换位思考，站在别人的立场上。
I'm Ira Glass-- back next week with more stories of "This American Life."
我是艾拉·格拉斯——下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "GAME FACE" BY TOKYO MASSAGE]
[音乐 - Tokyo Massage 演唱的《Game Face》]